aviadores estadounidenses en la base de
la fuerza aérea de dover en delaware
cargan equipo bélico incluyendo armas y
municiones con destino a ucrania el
pentágono ha puesto en espera unos 8500
soldados estadounidenses para un posible
despliegue en europa en medio del
incremento militar de rusia cerca de la
frontera con ucrania voy a trasladar
tropas estadounidenses a europa del
estoy a los países de la otan a corto
plazo
el jefe de las fuerzas armadas de los
eeuu dijo que el conflicto en ucrania
aún puede evitarse pero advirtió que
esta situación es diferente a las del
pasado
esto es mayor en escala de alcance en la
concentración de fuerzas que cualquier
cosa que hayamos visto en la memoria
reciente y creo que habría que
retroceder bastante los días de la
guerra fría para ver algo de esta
magnitud
los esfuerzos diplomáticos continúan
entre rusia y occidente el viernes el
presidente vladimir putin habló por
teléfono con su par francés emmanuel
macro los dos coincidieron en la
necesidad de desescalar pero putin
aseguró que la respuesta de eeuu y la
otan no tuvieron en cuenta las
preocupaciones fundamentales de rusia
entre ellas de impedir la expansión de
la otan y negarse a desplegar sistemas
de armas de ataque cerca de la frontera
de rusia más de 100 mil soldados rusos
están desplegados en la frontera con
ucrania y el presidente del país ha
pedido a líderes occidentales que eviten
el pánico ante el incremento militar
exchange a la sensación de los medios de
comunicación es que tenemos una guerra
que hay tropas en las carreteras que hay
movilización que la gente está yendo a
algún lado eso no es así
necesitamos este pánico
en una creciente tensión moscú dijo el
viernes por la noche que había añadido a
varios funcionarios de la unión europea
a la lista de personas a las que se les
ha prohibido la entrada en rusia
considerando los responsables de
políticas anti rusas